voilà a bien sûr la tête par kasimi au
casino théâtre
attention sur le facteur jean-françois
bonjour facteur du courrier pour mercy
mercy at il mangé au voilà certains
d'entre vous m'ont écrit pour me dire
qu'ils avaient beaucoup aimé le jeu du
décor qui changent souvenez on n'y a
joué un jour il ya longtemps déjà
et bien aujourd'hui avec les enfants
nous allons y jouer à nouveau
vous êtes d'accord les enfants les
enfants viennent voir les ivoiriens
d'avoir une idée vous êtes tous là nous
allons jouer au jeu du décor qui change
mais aujourd'hui ce sera plutôt le jeu
du décor inattendu alors vous allez bien
regarder le décor du jardin l'île aux
enfants que vous connaissez bien
regardez le bien regarder les
personnages aussi casimiri la main là
ar on continue et on continue on
continue la visite garder dans les
arbres dans l'herbe les ballons regarder
les détails du kiosque
observez bien julie ou s'est regardé et
puis emile campagne notre facteur voilà
maintenant menée par ici alors qu'on
voudrait bien tout observer le décor du
jardin et les personnages vous sortirez
dujardin et quand vous reviendrez
certains détails inattendus sont apparus
vous devrez les trouver en serre est ce
qu'on va faire en faire deux équipes une
équipe parisienne
voilà une autre par là à chacune des
deux équipes je remettre un micro et
offrez leur reportage
les détails inattendus du jardin alors
sauvé vous allez bien garder à droite et
à gauche
regardez bien et vous aussi chez vous et
tout à l'heure on cherchera les détails
inattendus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien voilà ça y est nous avons
modifié les éléments du décor et les
costumes du jardin deal aux enfants
alors la première équipe m'appartient je
vous donne 30 secondes l'autre et qui va
tendre à côté du jardin et je vous
appellerai après c'est entendu et bouche
et vous vous cherchez vous observez bien
et vous n'optez c'était qui vous partez
à côté du jardin
alors attention john 30 secondes
allez-y chercher
ce soir le vent a changé de classe
ledent à changer de place le ballon est
sûre yem ballon sur les autres la halle
balles en plastique et qu'est ce qu'il a
de différent cheval au il est pas comme
les autres il est pas mal on classe et
bien on dîne continue continue encore
quelques secondes
ce fils ont été rapprochées là y'avait
il n'y avait pas de corde accrochée là
il n'y avait pas de chapeau accrocher la
barre octobre vous avez dépassé là
y'avait pas de chapeau c'est vrai et tu
m'as parlé de lui sont aussi oui bon
votre équipe
allez c'est à vous allez tous avec
jacques erika le micro et vous cherchez
vous cherchez 30 secondes hop c'est
parti le bal en est pas là c'est vrai on
l'avait déjà trouvé mais c'est une bonne
réponse ustache casimir vient nous voir
un petit peu
viens nous voir casimir a une moustache
ou et casimir a des points en plus
casimir et de quelle couleur il en a des
verts alors que normalement alors que
normal la france des orages uniquement
des oranges et les applis tiges et des
jaunes c'est bien alors ça c'est trouver
autre chose la flandre là le pilote
on s'inquiétait pas laïcité là bas le
buisson l'autre équipe l'avait déjà
trouvé mais vous étiez pas là oui c'est
une réponse n'est pas là le banc n'était
pas là il y a des bananes dans l'arbre
il n'y en avait pas tout à l'heure ah
oui et c'est pas d'alaigne et st
cherchez bien chaud le panier n'était
pas là et regards regardez aussi les
personnages de l'île aux enfants
vous aviez vu casimir meygal ya le
facteur ix à julie et hier françois
lourde et nous y sommes veste julia
minkowski le facteur tout dit il à une
reste mais il a exactement la même reste
au real c'est la vaysse des ptt
elle est bonne sa veste
il y avait une robe avant elle avait une
salopette mais avant il y avait le
tricot de francs soit là et maintenant
il dit plus voilà mon tricot
effectivement dans l'îlot z'enfants
d'imposer un tricot parce qu il fait
toujours beau tabac trop chaud et qui
tient en un simple un soleil qui fait
bon alors julie effectivement la robe du
jury il n'y avait pas de perroquets
là-haut sur la vie va on va voir on va
boire
voilà il est là et maintenant tout le
monde a eu d'histoire de 30 secondes
maintenant tout le monde n'importe les
réponses comme ça hein allez continuez
continuez y en a d'autres regards des
journalistes que j'ai regardé le panier
là bas qui n'était pas un panier qui
n'existe pas qui trompait l'avant il n'y
était pas il ya le petit lapin bleu si
c'est le cas si on l'avait déjà vu mais
c'est une bonne réponse dans le même
temps dans le camp s'appelle la mesure
mais julie les lakers s'étaient pas
fermer les volets la bave c'est une des
plus difficiles
higgins est une des plus difficiles je
ne sais pas si nos amis chez elle avait
vu les deux stores du casque de julie
sont fermés alors que tout à l'heure il
était pas ça c'est pas facile à trouver
regardez bien le facteur quand même
parce que ça m'étonne que il n'a pas une
casquette de jeanne d'arc
qu'est ce qu'il a sur lequel il a le
numéro 6 mais qu'est ce que c'est ça une
cascade dans les jambes il a quitté la
ville et vous êtes sûr que vous n'avez
pas oublié
oui lesquels mais qu'elle ya la chaise
la chaise de françois il y en a c'est
pourquoi parfois lâché françois paré
tabouret et quand même voir tous les
deux la montre et vous montez vous à nos
amis chez eux
qu'est ce que vous avez sur vous ils
sont des micros sur des micro et aux
douze étaient tout à l'heure les micros
six soldats et sur le banc ils sont
vraiment très observateur ils ont même
remarqué mes moustaches